oh wait this is sorry one second i just
realized something it's the wrong talk
this might be better
okay so
uh
i i'd like to thank the organizers uh
for inviting me
and um i'm gonna talk a little bit about
uh
there's this theme that's starting to
happen of people trying to take what's
been done on graphs and extend it to
higher order
interactions high order models and there
are a few people in this room who are
thinking about this and then this falls
under that category
this is joint work with
my former student john steenbergen who's
now at ui uic and uh carly clevens uh
who's at who's at brown
and um
just to show you know spectral graph
theory seems to have become quite
popular it's a wonderful book by
by fan chung and then you know you can
talk about page rank and how relevant it
is and this is i guess figure one from
the paper by jeff chiger where he
related the uh the laplace beltrami
operator to
an eigenvalues of it to the um
to the iso parametric constant and just
something that i kind of thought was
kind of cute and maybe appropriate for
here is uh we are in the simon's
institute and
uh when he talked about this problem uh
this is something that jeff cheater
talked to jim simons about anyways but
we'll come back to a variation on this
picture later on but this picture will
be important um
so it has many applications and just to
list a few uh markov chains we saw some
of that clustering ranking methods
dimension reduction
semi-supervised learning is something
i'll come back to and it's also been
used in isomorphism testing and i just
wanted to show one example and you know
uh this is just advertised what misha
had done so
uh this is a dimension reduction method
laplacian eigenmaps where you take your
data you construct an association matrix
you compute the graph laplacian you look
at the top eigenvalue well you look at
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of that
and then you'll notice that the first
eigenvector is all ones it corresponds
to the eigenvalue of zero and then
there's this gap we'll be talking a lot
about this gap lambda 1. you can map
these points into the top k
looking from the left eigenvectors and
this has some geometric hopefully
intuition and here's just uh a nice
video that was made by dino shinran and
uh parthenoge where you have a bunch of
images of digits this is a digit
database this has been projected into
three dimensions
and we're going to be zooming in here
and you're just kind of seeing what the
actual structure is and let's just argue
that for things like dementia induction
or clustering
you know spectral methods you know may
make some sense again
one argument for why this may work
and if you want to kind of make the semi
topological is well if you want to find
near connected components this is
looking for near zero homology so this
again you can think of as a dumbbell and
you can ask okay
what are the near cuts of this right and
if you have data this can be
reformulated
into a clustering problem you have a
bunch of points you want to cluster them
and
so that's one problem we'll talk about
that's kind of the chiger notion of a
cut and the other problem we're going to
talk about is defining random walks on
simplicial complexes so again going from
perhaps to higher order forms and this
is the idea of label propagation and
this is
something that the jerry had had worked
on
a while ago and the idea is if i have
some labeled points here class one class
two the blue squares are unlabeled
points somehow i can run a random walk
or diffuse information and these all get
colored red these all get colored black
and we'll come back to that for higher
order notions so
coming back to graphs
if you want to talk about something
called the trigger number of a graph
what i have is i have a bunch of
vertices they're connected by these
edges and what i'm asking you as the
trigger number is okay
this is the number of edges between s
and its complement
i put a delta here because this is going
to be what's called a co boundary
operator soon i'll define it but i want
you to kind of think that you're
thinking in terms of chains and code
chains so that's why there's a delton
it's a cardinality of that and you're
just looking at the minimum of the
cardinality of s and s complement and
you can think of as this as a cut and if
this is zero then the graph is
disconnected so this is
uh
basically an isoparametric constant one
can think of a relaxation of this or a
rally quotient version of this and this
is what's called sometimes the feedler
number or the algebraic
number and here what i'm doing is i'm
relaxing this i put in function values
on the nodes and i'm looking at just the
distance or the square of the function
values for two adjacent nodes squared
divided by some notion of the norm of
the function values and you want this
perpendicular to the one vector this
idea of being perpendicular to the one
vector
will come up again in a more abstract
sense
and you can think of this as a
relaxation of this of the previous
problem and if lambda again is zero the
graph is disconnected
and the classic form of the trigger
inequality at least for graphs was uh
uh so nogalon studied this for expander
graphs millman was very interested in
kind of
some notion of geometry of this lawler
and sokol looked at this uh for the case
where he also had absorption and percy
talked a little bit about this the uh
the other day uh freeze kanan and
paulson studied this for markov chain
theory and again there's uh there's very
nice work by daiquinos and struck on
this as well and basically what you can
say is you can bound
the
that eigenvector eigenvalue by the
isoparametric
constant so this this was kind of the
main idea of the trigger number and the
reason why this became relevant often is
initially in studying expander graphs so
if i have a family of random graphs
let's say a sequence of d regular graphs
increasing with i
expander graphs are going to be those
that as i get a larger as the sequence
gets larger all of these have a positive
cut okay and the one of the uses of this
was
this could be the isoparametric truck
constant may be hard to prove that it's
greater than zero for this family but
you can show that the often you can show
that the uh the spectral gap is greater
than zero using simpler techniques so so
that that was part of the idea and the
motivation
so the other kind of
idea and direction is there's a very
natural relation between
the harmonics of the graph laplacian and
the stationary distribution of a random
walk so if i give you an association
matrix i can turn this into a
probability transition matrix and i can
relate and i can work out the stationary
distribution here and i can tell you
that the harmonic is related to that
stationary distribution and we'll come
back to this type of statement but again
not on graphs on simplicial complexes
okay
so this is what i was just saying we're
going to try to move from graphs to some
facial complexes so you might have you
know triangles tetrahedron so on and so
forth and and one reasonable question is
um
why
so here's a problem this is a problem
it's a sensor network coverage problem
and these are problems that some people
in uh
algebraic topology have been looking at
this is uh rob greist and vin de silva
have done some very nice theory on and
then other people like ali jadbabae
and some of his colleagues have been
looking at you know applied versions of
this problem and you can think of this
you're flying a plane around and you're
getting information on local areas and
you don't have gps but what you do have
is you know the connectivity locally and
from this you want to do computations to
figure out is there a hole so that's a
version of this problem uh where you
start actually looking at these
simplicial complexes there have also
been versions of this problem which are
ways of thinking of higher order notions
of pagerank
so think about a bunch of authors say
these three people have published ten
papers together okay these people have
published four papers together you can
think of building this out and then you
can ask okay how can i think about some
type of ranking structure here so so
that's this is a motivation and uh the
ranking problem i think the next talk
actually i don't think the next talk is
by luck england and he will talk about
the ranking problem and make that more
concrete okay so just for motivation and
that's probably about as much motivation
at least in terms of apply problem i'm
gonna give him this talk but um
just we're gonna come back and think
about some notions of homology so here
we're just saying that
betty zero is a number of connected
components betty 1 is the number of
holes and betty 2 is the number of voids
and so this is a way of
characterizing this
and what we'll come back to
is
these numbers can be thought of
algebraically and i'll tell you how
that's done and these numbers can be
thought of algebraically by looking at a
higher order notion of the laplacian
something called the hodge operator and
we'll come back to that but the
intuition i want to say is
spectral clustering in a way is looking
for near zero homology that is one
perspective on it i'm not saying it's
the only but that's one perspective on
it and so what happens if we do want to
do spectral clustering but to find near
holes right can you use a higher order
notion of the laplacian to do that so
that that's that's one way of thinking
about this problem okay
so the picture that i want you to look
think about is um
the the the dumbbell right the
diphyomorphism of the dumbbell was very
useful motivationally to think about
betty zero and near near cuts there
right so now i want you to think about a
hockey puck right take the middle of it
and start pinching it down towards a
taurus okay and that's the analog notion
for near one homology okay so that
that's a picture kind of the analog of
the cheeker dumbbell that i want you to
have and
you can do that if you had some dough or
donut material so
um
so this is uh this is a
picture
this is actually a pinched hockey puck
doug arnold generate this using finite
element methods and uh what i'm showing
you is what the one
the eigenvectors of the one laplacian
look like i'll formally define all of
these but i wanted to give you kind of a
picture and what you see is these are
kind of notions of flow and
what you want to do what if you want to
think about cuts it's like basically
like cutting the flow but as i pinch
down and more the flow is going to get
stronger and stronger is kind of the
idea and
one can do the same thing and think
about it this uh
same thing
this is actually we're taking a solid
hockey puck
okay it's it's solid we're taking the
middle and we're pinching it down and
the amount of pinch
is um
the amount
the the thickness in the middle is the
x-axis
i should have written the axis i'm sorry
and the y-axis is e is the eigenvalue
okay so you figure when it gets pinched
down completely right the eigenvalue
should go to zero and that's where the
distance is zero and as i get it bigger
bigger it gets increases so so this is
just uh again same type of picture
numerical illustration of what happens
with that now one thing that's
interesting is if i did this with a
non-solid hockey puck if i just did it
with a shell of a hockey puck anyone
have a guess what would happen to that
eigenvalue
what would it do it would do nothing
right because it's just it's different
to a sphere right it would do nothing
until it pinches through okay so again
just
just some pictures um
so related work
so in a very kind of discreet
perspective the tadzuk and patodi
studied romanian structures and
triangulations of manifolds i would say
kind of from the theory field
uh
there's really beautiful ideas by lineal
and mushulum studying
they had a random complex model which
i'll show you later on and really trying
to understand properties of that and one
way you can think about that is
extending the
urdish running model on graphs right to
these higher forms uh i'm going to come
back to that this is work by dominic
dutter and matt kale on defining
co-boundary expanders
i'm going to touch on this as well these
are negative results on trigger numbers
um this is another paper looking at
[ __ ]
isoparametric inequalities but it's a
different notion of [ __ ]
numbers than we're going to talk about
here
this is work we've done and
i'll tell you what it is
what we've done is actually very related
to some things that fanchung has done on
random walks and local cuts on graphs
and deer chalet graphs and i'll mention
some of that later on and then there's
this kind of i you know avi vickerson's
worked on this and there's work that
prasad's done that's related to this so
this is kind of uh just a short list of
some of the the simplicial complex
laplacian work now the random walks on
simplicial complexes there's less if you
uh don't think about very abstract
versions of it which are random walks on
groups and things like that and that's
uh some work by oli porzinski and ron
rosenthal and work that we've done and
these are quite related and so when i
tell you about our work
you'll effectively also learn about
their work and i'll tell you okay
okay so let me just give you some
definitions so simplicial complex convex
hall
k plus one alpha and independent points
we'll just define the mu zero through uk
a face of of tau um a face tau of sigma
is a convex hull of the non-empty sets
of none of the subsets of ui
so again um
when we define
an abstract simplicial complex it's a
finite collection of simplices such that
any face of a simplex
and k is also in k so if i gave you a
triangle i couldn't remove one of the
edges that would not be legal and the
intersection of two simplices is a face
of both simplicities can't take a
triangle and just stick a edge right in
the middle that would not be legal okay
so that that's that's kind of what we're
saying um
simplicial complexes tend to be
orientations oriented so you have this
notion you can have orientation this way
or that way these are equivalence class
of even permutations this orientation is
going to arise again when i talk about
random walks this orientation is going
to cause
something that looks different than the
standard rando walk on the graph and
you'll see how
but this idea of orientation will come
up and it's it's something that's a
little bit different than for graphs
so they're kind of two ideas there are
there are two types of operators there
are
chains and code chains boundaries and co
boundaries and we'll talk about that a
little bit so so if this is my
simplicial complex what does a boundary
do it takes an edge takes it into two um
well vertices right so boundaries always
take chiro-order
complexes into lower-order complexes if
you want to think of it as a map
here same thing applied to a triangle
we're breaking it up into these and if
you'll notice typically
not typically almost always we'll write
things as alternating sums again because
of this algebraic topological
construction you have these alternating
sums you'll see them again and again
okay
so again i told you we're going to have
chains and cochains so if i have a
simplicial complex of dimension m
what i think about in terms of chains
these are linear combinations of
oriented case simplices f is going to be
a field i'll tell you why i'm just
calling it a field in a second
and then you have code chains which are
functions on these simplices okay so
one's a linear combination of the
simplices the other ones are functions
on the simplicities now the reason why
i'm using a field f is i'm going to use
two fields one's going to be the reals
the reals are going to be used when i'm
thinking about the rally quotient the
relaxation to get that eigenvalue okay
and the other one i'm going to use is z
mod 2 z mod 2 is going to be used when i
want to get the isoparametric right so
you think about that zeros and ones
you're doing basically binary addition
and it's just splitting things up into
sets so that that's that's the logic
there
okay so chain complex like i said before
you have these chains you're applying
these boundary operators and they're
moving you down coaching complex similar
idea you have um these
chains you're playing the co-boundary
operator and you're going up so almost
all the results in this direction was
first done looking at code chains
because
when you think about a graph you're
really looking at a code chain because
you're not going to be going down
because then you know you're going from
vertices to in a way nothing uh reduced
homology it's it is formally nothing um
but when you think about going from the
vertices to an edges you really are
thinking about a coaching so a lot of
this this machinery was first developed
for coaching complexes now the boundary
map can be defined again as this
operation which is you take a point out
and then you take the alternating sum of
the
of the sub vertices i'll actually show
you a picture of this so you don't have
to
parse it and now this is in red i'll
tell you why this is in red the co
boundary map is sticking it in and then
doing something very similar it can also
be thought of the transpose of the
boundary map now
in the context that we'll be talking
about today
this is a little this statement is a
little bit shady this these two are
transposes that's certainly true
formally calling this a boundary and a
co-boundary map
is strongly it's developed in a theory
called daram theory and it's a beautiful
differential theory and you need
something called identification of
of of of these vector spaces right and
in a way we don't have clean
identification of these vector spaces we
force them and
because of that some of the results
we're going to get
the reasons why we can't prove things
[ __ ] inequalities in certain cases i
think arises from that and i'll give you
a little bit more intuition about that
but that's why it's a little bit in red
i was just afraid if there was a real
differential geometer they'd come after
me and
the index goes from zero to k instead of
one together it should be yeah
yeah sorry about that yeah
okay um
i do
i try i try uh and so so you can think
about the homology and homology vector
spaces in terms of the kernels of these
operators
module of the images from coming from
above and similarly for the comology you
can define it this way and we'll talk a
little bit about that now i wanted to
show you a picture so this is
if this is my simplicial complex and
these are the values i've put on it
right with these orientations if i hit
it with the boundary operator and i'm
working in uh
the real fields basically this is three
one one two you can do the addition
yourself that's that's what's going on
there and uh
if you do zmod 2
you get something similar you break it
up in terms of
now you're just doing a binary addition
and one can similarly look at what
happens to
what the co-boundary operators do and uh
for both in in the real fields as well
as in zmod too
just give a little bit of an intuition
now
something called the hodge position
sometimes
sometimes called the combinatorial
laplacian and uh
i i have a
so
there are two parts to it we call i and
some of my colleagues call them up and
down i'll explain to you why
but more formally what you're saying is
it's gonna it's taking a k form it's
spitting out another k form and what
it's doing is the up part takes it moves
it up by the co boundary
or and then brings it back down by the
boundary so it goes up and down and this
will be relevant in the random walk i'll
actually show you a picture of what it
means but think about it this way
if you had
vertices the first part would be taking
the vertices to
edges and the second part would be in a
way bringing it back down that that's
kind of the analog and then there's a
down part
which takes it from it uh you have the
boundary operator and k takes it to k
minus one and then you have a co
boundary operator k plus one so it moves
it up so another way you can think about
that think about a circle think about
tessellating the circle you have faces
right uh what you could be doing is
basically you'd be moving from a face
down to an edge back up to another face
that's another way you can think about
it okay
so this is a hodge laplacian
now
this is an important theorem this is
this is a theorem by ackermann and what
it sells you is the the laplacian
has a very nice property in that it
breaks up
this space into direct sum of three
parts one is
the kernel of
the laplacian and then the image of the
co boundary coming from uh
from delta k minus one and the image of
the boundary operator and these will all
give you some notion of the homology now
a very nice picture that i think gives
you some of this the intuition of what
this type of theorem does and let's say
for the one laplacian is something i
stole from pablo
which is
if you think about
vector space c1 you can break it up into
parts that are harmonic flows this is a
kernel of the laplacian parts that are
gradient flows right which is the image
of delta zero
okay and then parts that are basically
curls which are the image of the
boundary operating on one so that's
another way of thinking about it and
let king will actually talk about this
and lincoln will explain how this
picture can be used to take rankings and
break them apart into parts that are
consistent parts that are cycles but
long cycles and parts that are very
locally inconsistent yeah is there some
airing involved here because i don't
understand the definition of mk
meaning the previous slide in the
previous item
uh what do you mean by pairing i mean
how do you compose
delta k with the partial k plus one
right right right so right now just
think of it as a transpose
okay no
the the formal question of should these
be paired is tricky and and and this
goes back to there's a very nice paper
by uh
by
by doug arnold and others where they're
doing finite mesh methods and what they
and they want to show that in the limit
you get back the
the eigenvectors of the k form or the
eigenfunctions of the k form by doing
this and what they what they can show
there is for certain tessellations in
certain subdivisions you don't get that
pairing right so it doesn't quite work
out it's not consistent and for other
ones there are right and so this in a
way is uh
i think you've hit kind of
one of the main issues in all of this
right is we forced the pairing right and
one can ask if i go to a true manifold
finer and finer will that pairing be
reasonable or not right yeah
the other way of saying that they said
you put an inner product yeah exactly
exactly
once you fix a new product
yeah yeah exactly
okay so the trigger inequality uh the
way it was thought of we knew that it
held for manifold so one question we
said was okay as if we're going to be
doing this discrete stuff let's first
try and understand it on the discrete
analog of a manifold okay so that was
the idea so there
one very natural way of thinking of a
discrete analog of a manifold is you
take a manifold you
uh basically triangulate it right and
you call that your so collection of
simplicial complexes so that's kind of a
geometric notion now what we wanted to
do is we wanted to work with
combinatorial notions because the proofs
are much simpler so we used what's
called a pseudo manifold which is
basically what i just told you okay it's
just saying that uh i have a space it's
got a triangulation um
k
okay it's a union of all m simplices
every m minus one simplex is a face of
exactly two m simplices and it's
strongly connected this we don't need
but we'll use you'll come back to this
this is very much you can think of as
something like a dirschelle boundary
condition and i'll come back and point
that out
okay so
i think i told you about orientability
so two simplicities are laura jason if
they share a common d minus one face so
if you think about this
this is oriented
this is not oriented just to kind of
give you a picture and we'll come back
to that again
okay so
so the first
definition we started working with is a
chiger number on cochains and this comes
from a paper uh by dominic dutter and
and matt kale and uh there are two parts
of it this is the uh
eigenvalue part so if i think about the
co boundary operator okay f is in the
cochine space i hit it with the co
boundary operator look at the norm of
that and then just divide it by the norm
of f okay um
you can write it in this painful way and
i'll go through it
we're writing in this painful way
because what happens if you don't have
perpendicular if you don't if you aren't
working in some space where uh the the
normal is clear and you'll see why i
need to do that you can rewrite this as
again this is the same
now you're saying find an f
that's not in the image right
and then you're adding an extra dummy g
that is in the image and you want to
minimize that so these two are
equivalent and the way the reason why i
wrote this is that when we look at z mod
2 because i can't define
perpendicularity in z mod 2 and the norm
here is the hamming norm right i have to
work with this type of version but you
know morally this is doing the same
thing as this right for the z for the z
mod 2 but because i can't define
orthogonality
i'm doing it this way now
now an aside here
for those who make hair
is uh
ekman's theorem and the hodge
decomposition does not hold for zmac2
and this causes problems later on and
i'll mention that but that's kind of a
technical issue it does for the reels
okay and again i can read off um
i can read off call homology by checking
if these eigenvalues are zero uh this is
on the reels this is the mod two
so one of the things you hope and is
true is that you recover the graph
laplacian so l0 is just this part and
again you get back your trigger
inequality
now
even if you have nice pseudo manifold
it turns out that that we we can't you
don't get a trigger inequality for code
chains and what you have
is
you can i'm sorry you can construct
sequences and i'll show you how of
pseudomanifolds that have the following
property in that um
okay both
both your eigenvalues and your eigenvec
and and the both the the and the
isoparametric forms are going to zero
but they're going to zero at very very
different rates is what you're finding
so in this case one's going at a rate
one over k as you increase k and the
other one's going much much faster right
so so this is what you find and the
example is something that's called a
stellar subdivision and what's
interesting is if you look at uh doug
arnold's paper where they asked about
you know finite element methods and
meshing it this is one way of measuring
that will not work and the basic idea is
that you take your simplicial complex
find the berry centers and all for all
of them except for the outside ones
subdivide okay and then iterate this and
then this this won't work um
now an open question
is
are there do there exists good families
right somehow well defined as good for
which this type of problem won't happen
and i believe that is related to the
identification issue you need an
orientation hypothesis because if things
are oriented an example is a real
projective plane where uh your lambda is
not going to be zero and your h is going
to be zero so you need that now what
happens if you just completely
again re release the orientation
hypothesis and um
well what you find is that this is a
proof by anna gundert and uli wagner
where they use the combination of they
use the probabilistic method to prove
that they're infinite families of
complexes that are not combinatorially
expanding so lambda is zero but the
eigenvalues are away from zero all of
these have torsion none of these are
pseudo manifolds and uh just to show a
picture from matt kale they're using the
linear michela model where you throw
down
this object and then i basically start
throwing down random complexes and
that's what i'm looking at
now
turns out you also need this boundary
hypothesis this is related to sometimes
how we normalize the graph laplacian
if you have a picture like this and you
just start building up on the edges and
building up on the edges here h1 is
always going to be two-thirds but lambda
one is going to go towards zero yeah so
here
in order to simulate
so
all the edge in the graph laplacian
an edge is cut or not it is
being treated as uh
something over the field f2 and that's
how yeah the gmat ii
yeah yeah another way to look at it
would be
to
think of cheaper as a relation between
l2 and l1
so
instead of cuts think of it as just an
l1 embedding on the line yeah yeah yeah
we i mean this is interesting so the one
of the things we've been stuck with this
is relevant is is is i don't we don't
have hajj theory right for zima ii so
the idea of going to l1 or the idea of
going to a rational field and then
restricting it to be you know zero or
one things like that we're starting to
play around with that i wish i could
tell you that we've made success but we
have not but yes
yeah
okay so you can do the same thing on
chains right now you're just looking at
the boundary operator instead of the co
boundary operator everything that i said
is before um i just this is just the
same exact thing except for looking at
the boundary operator and now if lambda
h is 0 i can tell you about uh homology
being trivial and um so
for this we have a [ __ ] inequality
and it looks like kind of the standard
one
i think this might the denominator might
look slightly different but
and this is for an orientable pseudo
manifold we need it to be orientable we
need it to be a pseudo manifold and this
is a discrete analog of the [ __ ]
inequality for manifolds with bound with
additional boundary conditions so if you
go back to the 1970 paper uh you have
results for manifolds with boundary
manifolds without boundary one can think
of these as dual of each other and uh we
know for example when people study the
laplace beltrami operator on zero forms
or functions that this corresponds to
the case with neumann boundary
conditions when you look at them above
uh
of the 4k form it corresponds to the
case with dirichlet boundary conditions
and what's interesting or tricky is what
happens in between and there's something
called uh the bachner weitzenbach forms
which i think uh le king will talk about
that happen in between and that are more
kind of complicated so but again you get
this positive result on chains and um
so that that's so far what we know about
these trigger inequalities on these
simplicial complexes
i'll study some more when we conclude
then i just wanted to give you some of
the random walk stuff i'll go through
that a little bit fast but um
you have an association matrix you
construct the formal form form
standard uh transition probability
matrix right and what do we normally ask
questions about we ask about is there a
stationary distribution if you start at
some mu0 iterate and then you're going
to ask a question about the mixing rate
and then often this mixing rate is a
function both of the number of iteration
as well as the eigen gap right so these
are kind of very standard classical
ideas okay
um
there's an algorithm it's called label
propagation maybe in the interest of
time i won't give you the details but
the idea is you can use this random walk
idea to
do that classification problem i showed
you earlier with the red and the black
right you're basically iterating random
walks and um looking at certain values
of them
so again like we said the caleb flashing
has two parts
uh you can define random walks based on
each part so if you look at the the the
up version right you're going from an
edge to a face back down to an edge
and similarly you can define the down
version which is you start at a face
you go down to an edge and then you go
back to up to a face now
we're first to find the the walk
corresponding to the down part so this
is a part corresponding to the chains or
this is the part corresponding to the
boundary operator so i have a x is a d
dimensional complex this is just the max
degree now i'm going to generate a state
space which uh these things have
orientation okay so x has a bunch of
complexes and basically i'm going to
double the number each complex is going
to be written down twice one for each
orientation right that's what the
plus minus mean and theta is a death
state right well you'll see why there's
a death state a little bit but uh this
is a little bit related to what uh percy
talked about when you have random walks
with absorption so that's a death state
okay so
two oriented k cells
that have the same orientation are
considered neighbors that share k minus
one face
okay okay and then my transition matrix
is
i can move from
okay the i can move from a positively
oriented face to another one
or i can move from a negatively oriented
face to an another one
it's a lazy walk so the probability of
staying is p this is my probability of
moving and this is otherwise
this is my probability of switching
orientations
and this is a probability of going into
a death state which is actually a
boundary and then once you're at that
state you don't come out so this is
basically defining a transition matrix
and my goal is to tell you that the
stationary distribution of this
transition matrix has to do something
with the
uh eigenfunctions of lk down right so
i'm going to want to tell you that
and in spite of my shirt i want to be
correct
so what we typically study is you take
this transition matrix you start with an
initial probability vector and you
iterate this
now what we're going to find
and you ask about stationarity of this
object
one of the things that's kind of
interesting and we're still trying to
understand is because of orientation the
actual object that we're going to find
is the analog of the stationary
distribution and is related to the
harmonics of this of the operator is the
difference between
uh iterating on the plus oriented
faces minus the negatively oriented
faces right and so i can think of an
operator t that just looks at the
difference between these two
and one way of thinking about it is just
if i have two faces that have the same
orientation it's a one
i need two that are different in minus
one
so now what i can do is start with an
initial distribution just on any face
okay that's what i'm doing i start with
any face
iterate this p this transition matrix n
times okay hit it with this t this is
just the normalization constant that
has to deal with uh what happens because
of the absorption right and this
is what i'm going to say
this is our notion of
the stationary distribution right and
it's really
renormalizing just this quantity okay
just multiplying it by a constant and we
want to say something about the
convergence of this
as well as saying how it's related to
the harmonics
okay and what you can show is if your
walk is lazy enough
then this limit exists
assuming that you started any face tau
and the k thermology group of x with
coefficients in r is trivial if and only
if this is in the image of the
of the boundary for all tau and we can
also give you a rate of convergence now
there's an interesting point here is if
i were talking with graphs there'd be no
tau right because if we have a graph
it's irreducible no matter where we
start we know that it's going to a
stationary distribution right and i'd
really like to be able to say that to
you right here but i don't know how to
cleanly define irreducibility for this
case and it's because it's because of
orientation it's not just me uh orley
pravdan's custody and ron rosenthal also
have had a hard time defining
irreducibility because it's not just if
something can in theory get to something
else because of orientation you can get
messed up in how it gets there right so
so
if anyone has a clean
explanation of irreducibility that would
be great we're thinking about it right
so that's kind of one of the differences
now um
what was done in the paper by project
and rosenthal was for the up graph but
they never defined
they never defined a markov transition
matrix they defined something else which
they called a propagation matrix
which
had this form well slightly different
but basically it had negative numbers in
it
right uh and the negative numbers come
from this kind of switching the
orientation but once you write down this
matrix b this can be written basically
in terms of the laplacian so this is
something very much like what we see
think about this
forget about the stupid constant right
you just have i minus a laplacian which
is something you know we see more of
okay so that's kind of what they work
with so you can also work with that um
okay
now you can do the same thing for the up
walk now you're looking at co-neighbors
right
and then you can define again this type
of markov transition uh matrix
and you actually turns out don't need a
death state here you could put it in and
i'll tell you a little bit about that in
a second
so
so this is what they did they used this
walk
but they didn't define that they didn't
define this matrix they defined the b
version of this
and what you can say is if k is d minus
one
and every case simplex has at least one
coface then you don't need the death
state and that's the situation they're
looking at the threshold for detecting
homology
uh
is this is what you need for the neumann
walk which is the one that they worked
on and it depends on k which is the
order of the simplex when you look at
the dear chile walk this is the
threshold of detection and it depends on
the vertex degree the analog of the
degree so it doesn't depend on k so
these are some of the differences you
have between the walks
you can similarly define a walk by
the probability one half moving up
or down and recently a postdoc that
works with me omar babrowski has a
cleaner formulation of this which
hopefully we'll have written down soon
you can define a propagation matrix
again and you can say something about
the spectrum of this walk um in the
interest of time i'll not
talk about that
so
there's an algorithm i'll quickly go
through this and i'll show you a picture
the idea of the edge propagate the label
propagation algorithm again with you
have a bunch of points you have a random
graph some of the points are labeled red
some of them are blue i'm going to
propagate out the red points properly
get out the blue points if any point has
a greater probability of being red you
call it red greater probability of being
blue you call it blue very roughly
speaking right
we can do the same thing here but with
propagating edges so let me show you a
picture
actually before i show you this picture
let me show you this picture okay
so
this is a red edge so this is my
simplicial complex i'm looking at
triangles this is a red edge this is a
blue edge these have two different
orientations and what you can do is you
can basically run this algorithm which
is propagating edges so you believe the
relationships you care about are
pairwise relationships on these higher
order structures you can propagate them
and you can again do this type of
labeling so this is an example of edge
propagation and uh
what i wanted to show here is
this is my simplicial complex i've
labeled one of these red with this
orientation and i can propagate with the
up
reflection i can propagate with a down
laplacian and i could propagate
with both
this should look more flow-like this
should look more curl-like and these may
possibly look more harmonic-like but you
know
at least we get something but anyways
but these are things we're still trying
to understand okay um
and with that let me actually just tell
you some open problems do you have all
the triangles
i'm sorry do you have all the triangles
do i have all the triangles what do you
mean by that uh the triangle faces
oh
i i didn't i didn't
i was only propagating edges so i wasn't
propagating the faces
okay
but yeah this is this is a triangular
these are triangles right you're yeah i
didn't draw them in i'm sorry yeah i
should have drawn them in um so one open
question is com the how
does a combinatorial oblation converge
to the laplace beltrami on forms um
this one is going to be the next talk
you're going to learn a lot more about
point number two uh i think it's really
interesting what is a continuum limit of
this random walk is it something like
brownian motion on forums i really don't
know
but i really want to understand
understanding irreducibility hitting
times and things like that and and for
the der chile walk i think a lot of
things we did can probably be made much
nicer by this idea of hadoop transform
that persia talked about before but
um
and one of the things that we're still
trying to understand is the cheater
number both well for manifolds but also
for these discrete structures for the
middle dimensions we can tell you
something for the top dimension now and
the bottom dimension the middle
dimension is still open and well in
1970 jeff [ __ ] said it would be good
to understand it and we're i guess still
working on it uh and uh there are people
who gave money i'm not sure for this
and uh they're people who i talked to
and were helpful
and um yeah so thank you
good question
so i mean the other way to think of this
is the classic way that blessings came
out was for solving
spring mass systems or for solving a
heat equation yeah
so the natural generalization would be
maxwell's equations right
electromagnetic radiation
and in some sense you're doing that
right i mean but you never mentioned
that i did never mention that and so
and in some sense it
probably works nicely when there is a
natural analog of
elect you know electromagnetic radiation
you have flow on the edges which induces
magnetic fields which induces and so you
should be having two things
you know a magnetic term and an
electrical term
so okay so
these are examples you talked about
those but you didn't use those words i
didn't uh so i'm really a horrible
physicist but but more more more
seriously it's it's there and if you
look at some of my colleagues like
people like anil harani he does think of
things that way and some of them you
know if you also look at some of the
things that i maybe i shouldn't put
words in pablo's mouth but you know you
also think a little bit right
in the game case yeah in the game case
right so so there is that kind of
perspective there and and when you look
at the one laplacian it's very much
there you really are looking at curls
all of that is is very implicit there um
zero laplacian then you're looking at
electromagnetic field yeah
energy versus sure sure and and you know
there's maxwell's equation you have the
the chile boundary condition form like
the heat equation right so those are all
there and i mean
i'm sorry
that's a hodge decomposition right so
yeah absolutely those are all there um
uh i guess the question is why didn't i
use those terms uh
i don't know uh physics is hard for me
maybe i i don't i don't
but i mean it's very fair and i mean
what i will say this is
me and my colleagues we really do think
moving back and forth between the
discrete perspective and the continuous
perspective and that's been very helpful
in getting some intuition so i will say
we certainly do that
and i mean in some of these papers i
read when i look at the hajj
decomposition and you know you look at
um
you know the very physics versions of
this you know you read these papers and
you can start making those exact
connections i i just use this language
you